Did you guys see the influencer about the, that,
that pretended she got in a motorcycle accident and then shot it.
Either way. It's bad, either way it's bad.
Don't go.
Cousin. One time said he didn't want to go to college.
And they obviously had been brewing with between him and his dad.
And my uncle said to him, right when he said he cut him off.
Then don't go. Don't go. Don't go, Nick.
Don't go. And it was like, so mad, you know?
Anyway, he went, um, so, uh,
yeah.
Influencer is defending her decision to post a photo shoot of her motorcycle
accident on Instagram. Hey.
Bye dude. Bye bye.
If I will.
In an airplane and I was going to do a, uh,
skydive and I wasn't sure, and I was nervous.
And then somebody just pulled that up and showed it to me. I jumped out.
Then I got, it. Who cares if it doesn't open.
She also denied to me that Smartwater featured in one of the professional that,
that the Smartwater featured in one of the professional photo shoots is a brand
endorsement.
He's a dude. Me. So she put.
This was on Buzzfeed. I mean, a lot of people picked it up. I tweeted about it.
I said, how influencers suck, dude, just get a job, man.
You know what? Don't get a job. Don't get a job.
Develop, actually develop period, get up, get up a
skill, develop a skill, dude.
Don't just sit near a, you know,
umbrella. And then,
and then have some dude take a picture.
You see these dudes take the pictures, all.
Squatted out with their, with their hands, like.
All. This is me. This is what this girl says. [inaudible].
Or something.
This is me and my bike about an hour before I got into an accident.
And if you watch my story Sunday, you know all about it. But if you didn't,
here's the scary, magical series of events.
A few of us wrote down to Lee Leaper's fork Saturday to explore and take
pictures. Yeah, you didn't go to explore. You went to go take pictures.
My sweet friend, yada yada was shooting and my other sweet friend,
yada yada was riding while a friend of Lindsay's drove the Jeep. All right,
dude. You know, we don't need all this. Okay, cool. What is this?
The describing back into the left, back into the left.
This is like the JFK trial. So then she was driving and then the,
and then the other sweet friend was riding.
And then while Lindsay drove the dream Jeep, we don't give a.
We played around for a couple hours before heading back up to Nashville
course, course they were going back to Nashville
and uh, around seven 30 and on a secluded two lane stretch,
I misjudged a curve, took a too fast and my bike went off the road.
It slid to the grass and I hit the pavement. I had my helmet on,
so my head was fine, but I yada yada. Yeah.
And then in the.
The whole time I was listening to the main attraction. That's what she said.
Exactly word for word. And um, so.
Uh, this.
Was so she did the thing made the tweet,
made the Instagram and then like
they got pictures.
Of her w like.
In pain on the ground and this photographer was just taking pictures of it and
then posted it and filtered it out.
And it all fits the aesthetic on our Instagram.
Okay. Ooh.
You did the wrong thing. Bay Bay.
Dude, this is just so bad.
Yes. If she says the word event, adventure in the caption too,
everything's a adventure dude. To these checks,
everything is a adventure. They could lay in bed and be like today.
I just didn't. I just adventured with my pillow.
I just adventured watching the hostel, the hostel trilogy. Ooh,
scary. I need to go on an adventure like that.
Only without the rape and getting killed. LOL.
My friend was there to take her.
Pictures.
This, these aesthetics too, uh, that they have are all like,
always like Brown and tan these days.
It's crazy, dude. It's so crazy to me,
the world. And that's it.
How many, what? I'll follow up post? Uh,
she's sitting on her bike. Cool. All.
And that Smartwater was all placed in the earlier one, too.
This is a follow-up post. Cool.
I've been figuring out how to respond to everything that's unfolded recently
regarding the post I shared three weeks ago about my Modo accident at shortened
it, I won't get into the post here.
See my Moto accident story for highlighted for all the details.
S still promoting her accident.
Didn't learn all good keeps touching the hot stove,
but I want to talk about the reactions I've been getting to the article at
Buzzfeed news, posted sensationalizing.
What I went through that day and making a mockery of the post I shared.
Oh, Oh, Oh, Oh, Oh dude.
I don't say this word a lot, but sweet.
It's hard.
You were the one making a mockery of your accident when you put
gradient.
Is that the right way to say that? Who gives a dude?
When you, when you adjusted the gradient, is that how you say it?
I don't know when you opened the aperture. No.
Nothing about it. I've been accused of state as a result.
I've been accused of staging the accident to get attention.
Do you know why you cue you're accused? You know.
Why you were accused of that OJ?
Um.
Using it as a product placement opportunity with a water company.
I also don't get that part. I don't give a flying about,
I don't care about that. We're all suckers and kudos for drinking the. Anyway.
Who cares if they post it with an, with a fake accent?
I don't give a Smartwater. I mean, I drink it. I mean, I mean.
Can use that for a smart water ad.
More water. I drink it. I don't give a.
She crashed and put a Smartwater on the photo. I don't give a.
I'll take a shower in it. Give me more, put it up above my.
I'll take an outdoor shower with it.
I'll open up my mouth and just drink it while I wash my armpits with it. I E.
Um.
I've been using his approximate water company and other things I can't even wrap
my head around. Well, we wrapped our heads around it for you.
I've been sharing real life stories here. Since I started my account,
I've opened up about miscarriage, divorce, anxiety,
losing my partner in a motor accident three years ago,
and navigating grief that followed I've chosen to use Instagram as a tool for
healing and connecting with other humans who may be going through similar things
so we can do it together. And it's been beautiful when I work with brands,
they're ones I personally enjoy. And I just go to every single sponsorship,
accusing someone of faking or exploiting the accident is extremely serious
because of because what if you're wrong?
I really, it.
Really happened to me and I was scared.
I really was injured and I had to recover.
I was in chocolate and on the side of the road, having flashbacks,
when I lost someone, very important to me, friends were on my side. Look,
I don't even give a. If the really happened and the really happened.
What's what, what's the difference between us. It starts with the penis,
but if the really happened, that's fine. The problem,
I don't have the problem I have isn't with the fact that I
think it's a fake motorcycle accident.
As a matter of fact, that's better.
That's better than falling on the ground in a real way,
scraping the out of your tattooed shoulder and asking your
friend to take photos about it.
Because that's the way that we know he got mental
problems,
Staging. It is at least for the money,
But you falling down, hurting yourself,
having flashbacks from losing your partner to the same
accident and asking your friend to take
Grady and shots mean she got
mad props.
Yeah, I understand. Oh,
but it's tan.
It's all good. Yeah. Brains. All Dan Ted.
Dude. That's.
The hugest problem of it. All.
I crashed. Get out your camera.
That's not a sentence that you say,
Why are you acting like the not problem is the problem.
The only problem is the real problem. Dude.
I want to have a game show called the real problem. People come up and be like,
so, hi, I'm Nancy. And I own an accounting firm.
And now I want to tell you my problem wrong.
Yay. Well, Nancy, what's your problem? Well,
the problem is everyone thinks that I faked a motorcycle accident to
put on Instagram so I could do a deal with Smartwater.
[inaudible] we'll be right after these messages to decide what the real problem
is. Hey everybody, we're back.
It's vine out. The real problem. See, now here,
before the commercial break,
she said that there was a problem because we thought it was a brand and smart
water, but what what's the real power? Well,
I'll tell you what the real problem is. Her brains,
all dented up.
Join us next time for what's a real problem where we have a new contest.
Jeremy Renner, Hey, Jeremy Renner.
You're a successful actor and you got 400 quadrillion dollars.
What's the deal. You're an Avenger. And you're also in good movies,
like the hurt rocker. So what's going on, man? You want to do music? Well,
yeah, I always loved music and I, you know,
the real problem is never got a chance to do it. And now that I'm 45,
I got to change to do it. Oh, cool.
We'll be right back after these messages, psych we're back. Now,
the real problem is you just want to be more
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Anyway, dude.